هذا بالاضافه طبعا الى عمليات النهب
والسرقه والتي اصبحت متفشيه في السودان
وذلك منذ بدايه الصراع الذي اندلع قبل
حوالي سته اسابيع هذه العمليات لا تطال
فقط المحل التجاريه وممتلكات المواطنين
ولكنها تطال ايضا المستشفيات وتحديدا
تطالب المساعدات الغذائيه برنامج الاغذيه
العالم التابع للامم المتحده اوضح ان 17
الف طن من المساعدات الغذائيه المخصصه
للمحتاجين فقدت في السودان بعض المساعدات
سرقت من مستودعات والبعض الاخر من شاحنه
تابعه للمنظمه الامميه تقدر القيمه في
صوره كلفه الطعام بما يتراوح بين 13
و14 مليون دولار مع تلقي المنظمه تقارير
يوميه بشكل تقريبي عن عمليات سرقه اخرى
المنظمه العالميه تشدد على ان انعدام
الامن الغذائي في السودان اصبح الان يتسبب
في اعلى مستويات القلق لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات